hey Guardians we've got some new footage
from destiny twos lush Mossman European
dead zone we played well over 15 hours
of bungees upcoming sequel and saw many
interesting new additions to the game
such as the lost sector in dungeons and
the micro stories that take place in the
new adventure missions in this video
we're checking out one of the European
dead zones unique adventures called Dark
Alliance while the lost sectors explore
some rather obscure and remote spaces
the adventure missions tasks you with
helping some side characters which
spiral out and says some rather
unexpected events be sure to comment
below and subscribe to our channel for
more videos including some footage of
the lost sectors and exotics you might
find along the way thanks for watching
Yello Kate speaking oh hang on someone
left a note here
Edie's e forest taken energy question
mark red Legion Brian who's Brian red
Legion Saiyans Guardian we've heard
disturbing reports from your area they
tell of Kabbalah with new powers that
sounds ominous
we'll keep an eye out for any unusual
psionic energy near body
red Legion Saiyans are bad enough but if
they really have taken powers cabal and
Jake can start sharing toys anyway we
can figure out the connection later for
now we must uncover the source of his
energy
Scion is it shielding that century
that they are harnessing the energy of
the taken but how
taking energy readings are increasing
minutes spreading to science all over
the area if that's true it could bring a
plague of shadow beyond our imagining
got it
I pulled location data from that century
but we have to go into the forest you
sure about that buddy
don't want to get you know creepy tikal
shadow tree Hey
what exactly happened to you
[Music]
no they did not get eaten yet but use
caution we don't know what's waiting in
that forest my climbers on something big
in tickets that may be the safest bet
you've made in years
that portal connects to the forest the
science found a way to force it open
you
he got stunned when we took out his
Scion severing their bond must cause a
backlash to the host interesting am I
the only one who has no idea what any of
you are talking about yes
[Music]
hey there are a lot more cabal than I
was expecting well they may not like you
trespassing in their secret magic
big takin taking kebab big taking
caballes
of course you must destroy it
working on it
who did it they're all come well that'll
set the légion back away serves him
right for messing with things they don't
understand which is your area of
expertise after all as for you Guardian
well done if that brute had gotten loose
with the Saiyans there may have been no
stopping it
and then I couldn't have collected on
that bat they can take it soldier
take it push them back
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Debra we beat them of course you did
never had any doubts